Bomberman is a robot engaged in the production of bombs.
Like his fellow robots, he had been put to work in an underground compound at the center of the earth.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean.
I'm Joe.
And I'm Sam.
Full House for the very first episode of 1989, which I believe was also the first year that the show Full House came out.
Oh wow. It was 1989.
So we have a Full House, there's a Full House sitcom, we're doing great.
I've got a Full House as a hand of cards.
Does that mean we'll get a licensed NES Full House game?
You have to wait for Full House Tournament Fighter on Super Nintendo.
He had that all set up.
Yeah, Joe and I worked that through.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, actually, believe it or not, YouTube, yeah, like YouTube for Full House Tournament Fighter,
and you can watch like Uncle Jesse actually lay out some good moves on Uncle Joey.
Nice. He's not Uncle Joey, Mike.
He's just Joey. Oh, that's right.
Yeah, yeah. I knew something was weird about that.
I was like, they never, you know, they also called him that woodchuck, right?
Isn't he like, um...
Oh yeah. Yeah, wood.
Wood. Yeah, you know what I'm talking about.
Couple people watched Full House, heard it was a pretty successful show, but we're not talking about Full House or Full House Tournament Fighter.
We're talking about Bomberman.
Guys, is Bomberman an IP?
Forget about the games for a second.
Is Bomberman an IP you associate with the upper echelons of gaming?
Is he as familiar as Mario, Pikachu, Sonic, Crash Bandicoot, Spyro, Master Chief, Lara Croft?
Like, is he up there with these people?
All right, so I think with who you just listed, that's a combination of A-list and B-list icons.
Like, Bomberman is definitely like on that cusp between like B-minus, C-plus.
It's definitely more of a C-list gaming icon.
I put Bomberman in the same tier as Tails from Sonic.
Okay, I get that.
I get that. I could see that. I would think though that if like, like Tails is up there with Sonic, right?
Like, if Sonic's up there, then Tails is too.
Yeah, but if Sonic wasn't part of it, if it was just Tails, I think that's where Bomberman would be.
Okay, gotcha. If we set them all out on a line, I think that Bomberman would be below Crash Bandicoot, but above Knack.
Okay? And Joe, is Crash Bandicoot an A-list or a B-list character?
It's a B-list. Well, let me tell you, you're talking to a very biased Crash Bandicoot, giant Crash Bandicoot fan, so I'm gonna say A-list, but I'm sure not everyone will agree with me, judging by Sean's whisper a second ago.
I would say Lara Croft being listed was also a little strange, right?
Like, that's C-plus as well.
That's where I associate Bomberman.
That's B-minus. Here's the thing, though, is everyone that you mentioned, if we're just talking, like, our own personal experience, everyone that you mentioned, I knew something about.
Bomberman, I just knew the name Bomberman.
I didn't really know anything about it.
That's true. I knew that he had bombs.
So, that puts him a little lower.
Yeah. I think my only experience with Bomberman before this is from Smash Bros.
as an assist trophy.
Okay. Just for the most recent game, though, right?
Just for any kind of Bomberman experience, I think.
No, no, I'm saying, like, I only think Bomberman was recently an assist trophy.
Oh, yeah. He wasn't on the Wii U one.
No, I don't think so. Okay, that's interesting.
Guys, I grew up on Bomberman, so I'm a little surprised to hear this, but I could understand why, you know, I asked this as, like, a trick question,
because I think Bomberman is, like, a big deal in Japan and not a big deal out here in the West, and I'm not quite sure why that is,
but you'll see later on when we get into the sequels and spinoff section, I think it's gonna have to be its own show.
Like, technically, Bomberman is probably, like, Hudson's biggest, Hudson Softs, their biggest character by far,
just by looking at, like, the list of games that this guy has and, like, the amount of media support and all these other offshoots of it.
It's like, this is, this is like a big franchise for them.
I'm very surprised.
Oh, for sure.
I'm also just gonna say that I've never played a Bomberman game in my life either, but I had always heard of him,
and I, it looked interesting enough, so, cool.
So, Bomberman is a robot, might be a man, unlike decided on that.
The manual kind of tells us that, like, he was a boy or he's trying to become a boy.
It's like a Pinocchio story there.
But he's a robot who, as we mentioned on the back of the box, is stuck in the underground compound of the center of the Earth,
and he needs to find his way through a maze while avoiding different enemies and ultimately killing those enemies
as he uses his bombs in a top-down fashion to destroy bricks and enemies and bust down doors and find power-ups
to continue to advance on from stage 1 all the way to, I believe it goes to stage 50.
As I mentioned, the game is played top-down, and bombs explode in a four-way cross-direction at all times.
Anybody think that I didn't do the whole video game justice there?
Those are definitely the way that you play the game, yeah.
Well, did you mention that you evolve from level to level, and by the end of the game,
you're a very different move set than the beginning of the game?
Move set, ability set, than the beginning.
Because of the power-ups?
Because of the power-ups, which, yeah, are game-changing.
I guess technically you don't need to get the power-ups, but if you do, it evolves the gameplay over time.
No, I think that's a good point, because we should probably start talking about this game
at the most basic form.
Like, forget the power-ups.
When you first start this game, you're this little guy in a maze that looks not like a maze at all.
It's just a green background with a bunch of tiles placed around and some balloon enemies floating.
And you have to lay out one bomb at a time.
You don't have any more supply than that.
And your explosion of your bomb is only the adjacent four tiles in a cross direction.
So as you collect power-ups, obviously that expands.
But how did you guys feel about the initial power of Bomberman and also just the feel of the game?
Yeah. My specific non-experience with this game in the past made me think that, oh, this must be what old Bomberman feels like.
Because I've seen footage of the more modern games, and it's kind of chaotic, and it looks a lot more fun than this was.
This was kind of like pulling teeth.
And just because you don't get to choose when they explode.
You can only blow up one at a time, as you said.
And it's so weak.
But I did not realize that it was just sort of like setting the foundation to make you feel a bit more powerful down the line.
But I'm sure we'll get into that.
No, I have these images of what Bomberman is in my head.
Of these giant explosions that travel really long distances in four directions.
And I feel like when it just kind of popped on screen instead of exploding, it was very underwhelming.
But that the sound of the explosion was really sick.
Oh, yeah. I definitely felt that, too.
Like, this is the best explosion sound of the NES so far.
The best of 89.
Similar experience, too.
But I thought, just based on the look of the game, I kind of unfairly was like, well...
Based on the look and the first level, I was kind of unfairly like, well, this feels like a lot of the other arcade-style games that we've had.
It's probably going to be very shallow and not get much more complicated than this.
And it did, to an extent, prove me wrong.
But, you know, at the beginning, it kind of made me think I wasn't going to be that into it in the future levels.
It's surprising how slow the game starts off because I would argue that that's fine if this is your first ever time playing Bomberman.
But even you guys have, like, an idea of chaos in Bomberman games where there's usually, like, a bunch of different players.
Enemies are all over the place.
And they do fun things, too.
It's a little strange when the enemies that you're fighting just kind of move in, like, random directions, could care less about where you necessarily are in the stage.
And when you have to kind of wait for all progress to happen based on, like, this five-second delay between when you place a bomb and when it explodes.
Keep in mind, of course, that since we're describing these top-down levels as mazes, it's not so much a maze because you can always destroy the blocks in your path.
But there are a lot of blocks in your path.
So if we're talking lay down a bomb, five seconds to explode, open up, you know, a new direction, you have to do that a lot in a particular level.
And it's not that they don't give you enough time to do that or anything or that the levels themselves are too large.
It's a very tedious task to ask of a player who's just starting out in the game.
It's not very rewarding at first.
Would you disagree? Yeah, I would.
Because I was going to say, because I fully agree with you, that this was super risky.
If they knew what this game was going to be, like, in the late game or after you've sort of learned the ropes and you pick up some power-ups,
but you choose to show this as, like, how you're going to play the game,
and, like, as a person that may not have been exposed to Bomberman before,
like, thinking that this might be how the game is played the entire time,
it's just super risky to sort of, like, put your most boring foot forward.
I don't know, though. I feel like it might just feel more risky to us from the lens of today.
But if you think about, like, back then, it wasn't like today where it's like,
you pick up a game or you, I don't know, you try a game, you demo a game,
or just you have access to all these games, and then you're like,
oh, I don't like it, I'm going to try something else.
Back then it was just like, well, you play this game at first levels,
but you gave it a lot more of a chance, I feel like, in the 80s,
because it was the only game you had, or you only had a few games.
So, like, I feel like even the first level being boring,
I feel like it was less of a risk that, like, they're going to lose their,
people are going to just immediately put the game down
over, like, the reward of, like, having that boredom turn into, like,
people noticing, like, how different.
Sure. You know, like, say those first two to three levels where you're collecting,
I think, because I really think you can only get one power up a stage.
Am I right?
Like, it sounds about right.
I feel like maybe you could get two, but, you know,
pretend that those first three stages where you're just kind of slowly gaining
power ups, think of those as the tutorial stages, right?
I think that maybe is what Joe is getting at.
I would argue that those stages then don't need to be so large, though,
and so empty in their design.
They could have been smaller things that teach you about, like,
like, okay, well, remember, if you plant a bomb, like,
you got to have another corner or out point to go to,
otherwise you've kind of trapped yourself in your explosions.
Or, you know, these enemies go in a particular direction,
so make sure you don't explode every brick around them,
because then they'll just be free to roam,
and it's going to be a lot harder to destroy them.
Like, that's the kind of tutorial I would have liked to have seen.
Instead, you get the full game with not a lot happening.
Well, for the record, yeah.
Does that make sense, Joe? Well, yeah, I agree with what both of you are saying about this level.
Like, this level could be a lot better,
and it could be more exciting and more interesting.
I just don't think that it was necessarily much of a risk to them
in the perspective of 1989,
because it's not like,
I don't feel like a lot of people would play the first level
and be like, okay, I'm out back then,
like they would today.
Absolutely. Sure, sure.
Because you just bought the game.
You just paid full price for it.
Exactly, yeah, yeah.
I get that, but I get what you're saying,
but even something that has a more standard,
like, not difficulty curve,
but a curve of how complex the game can be.
Like, if we're talking about Mario,
if we're talking about Contra,
like, well, you're going to be doing the same things,
across the entire course of you playing those games.
Like, jumping in Mario is fun,
regardless of when you're jumping,
what level you're jumping in.
Shooting in Contra is fun,
regardless of what level you're in.
Whereas, planting bombs and waiting for them to explode,
and then once you somehow kill all the guys in the map,
then, like, just sort of combing through
every other little pixel
to see which one has the hidden door
is not all that fun.
So I think it's a little different.
Like, it is kind of riskier.
And it may have, like,
it definitely would have been helped
by a more modern take and tutorialization
that just hadn't been invented yet, really.
So I still think that it was a...
This was an interesting way to go.
Yeah, I mean, I see that, too.
But I do also think that some of the things
that you're saying are not fun in this first level
are also not particularly fun in later levels,
like combing through. No matter what your power-ups are,
once you've killed all the enemies on the screen,
combing through every brick, I think,
is maybe, at least in my opinion,
just a flaw in the game overall.
Sure. I'll grant you that.
So let's talk about the main power-ups here.
For the most part,
you're collecting additional bombs that you can drop
so that you can drop multiple bombs at a time.
And there's, like, a fire power-up, too,
that just increases the range of your explosion
so that instead of one tile in each direction,
it can go two, three, even four tiles
in a particular direction.
And that really helps speed up the gameplay
and add a lot of strategy to it, too,
because now you have to be aware
of where your bombs are,
where you are,
and where the, like,
points of exits and enemies are.
Because I would argue that
when you have a one-by-one tile,
you know, cross-directional explosion,
that it's really easy to dodge that.
And most of the time,
you're just going to get either, like,
you're going to put yourself in a bad planting position
where you accidentally planted it
and trapped yourself in a place,
or you trapped yourself with an enemy on the other side
so you can't escape either the explosion or the enemy.
Later on, all of a sudden,
you're actually your own worst enemy in this game.
I would argue that you're way too powerful
for the enemies in the game,
but you're now the threat.
Yeah, it kind of becomes a puzzle game a little bit,
as the more you play.
Oh, it's definitely a puzzle game throughout.
It's just so that the puzzles kind of change.
Yeah. Yeah, I'd even say that, like, at some point,
the way that you become stronger
did this weird thing where,
for a little while,
it made, oh, the puzzles are a little more interesting now,
because now I have to think about it this way.
And then after a while, it was like,
okay, well, now the puzzles are a lot easier.
Like, it made the difficulty curve, like,
not, like, continually increase.
I feel like there's a period of time,
you know, there's one point where you
eventually just have the ability
to detonate the bombs whenever you want.
Whenever you want, rather.
So you place it,
and you don't have to really worry about
where you placed it, because you can almost always find
somewhere that's safe.
You have all the time in the world to get there,
because you detonated it at your own time.
So I feel like,
not that it was necessarily made it, like,
pointless. It was actually kind of cool to suddenly,
at first, to suddenly have a,
an advantage where you didn't before.
But it did mess a little bit
with the difficulty curve of the puzzles.
Yeah, it's sort of like,
there's, there's like a tediousness meter
and a difficulty meter.
And whenever, like,
as the difficulty goes up,
the tediousness goes down,
because you're sort of giving more and more,
you're getting into more and more chaotic situations.
So, like, I still,
but, like, the fun continues to go up
in, in that situation.
I don't know if I'm making any sense there.
Yeah. No, I, I get it.
I see what you're saying. I think there's just something to
the satisfaction of seeing
your growth in this game,
which is, like, very clear.
Yeah. And it's also interesting,
because, so,
did you get,
uh, the power-up to
make the
explosions bigger before you got
the power-up
to time your explosions
yourself? I got one of the,
yeah, one of the power-ups
to make your explosions bigger
first, and then I think I got the
time one before I got the next
bigger power-up.
I don't remember exactly the word.
That's interesting, because I,
I didn't find,
uh, my first, like,
make it bigger power-up
until, like,
I was able to plant,
like, five bombs at a time,
and I could set it off
at my own pace, and I was,
like, a little bit faster,
um, so I also think that,
like, the fact that
the order in which
you get the power-ups
can make your experience
that much more different
as well. Yeah,
that's, I had no idea
that that was the case, that it,
that would actually totally change the game
in some instances.
Mm-hmm. Well,
Sean, it sounds like your strategy
wasn't necessarily
to bomb every single block
before you,
uh, entered the door
to go to the next stage.
Would I, would I be correct
in that assessment? You'd be correct.
I did not think I was supposed to.
I don't think you should
have to, but theoretically,
that is the best way
to get all the power-ups,
is by bombing
every single block,
and granted, you're gonna blow up
probably 50-plus blocks
and get two power-ups
in exchange, but your,
uh, scenario,
where you have the control
of five different bombs
that you can detonate
whenever you want, but they only do
one-by-one tile,
uh, cross-directions,
sounds like a nightmare
to me. like,
yeah, it's not, it didn't seem,
uh, the, the most optimal
way to do it because I,
like, at that point,
I did go back and play it
and I did eventually,
uh, get the ones
that made them bigger,
uh, but when I watched
the video of somebody
that was on the same
level as me, I think I was on,
like, level 15 at the time,
uh, and how they were playing,
it was just like, this is insane,
uh, and so when I,
as I played a little bit
longer, I was finally able
to find those power-ups
and, uh, kind of get to that level,
um, but yeah,
no, I mean, because there are other
things going against you,
like the timer that will
make it, make the,
um, make a bunch of extra
enemies spawn,
like, I'm not gonna clear an
entire level if I have
that risk, so,
uh, yeah,
it's, it's entirely possible
that a lot of people wouldn't have found all
those power-ups to
begin with anyway. So can you guys
confirm something for me
then? Is there, I just assumed,
based on my experience,
that there's only one
power-up per level,
so I played it like,
I would bomb every
single block until I
found the power-up and
the door, and then I would think,
okay, that's everything I need to find,
and I would move on, so I kind of found,
like, a little happy medium
with having to bomb every block,
and hopefully not
missing power-ups, unless there are times
where there's more than one power-up in a level.
I'm only going off of
what I remember, and I feel like I would
have, I feel like I remember
getting possibly two
at max per stage,
but it's very possible
that, you know,
it's just being a blur
to me now, and that I'm thinking of
later Bomberman games,
which just give out
power-ups like crazy,
because it's to add
to the chaos, so I can't say for certain
that this game gives you
two per stage or
something like that, but it's definitely not
more than two,
so it's either one or two.
Gotcha. You know,
what's funny is
controlling the bombs,
right, that's like a different
kind of power-up,
though, right? Like, the rollerblades let you
move a little faster,
the explosions
can become bigger,
the amount of bombs you can drop,
you can have more of those,
but being able to
control them is like an actual
new element
to the gameplay,
and what's surprising
there is
in a game like this,
it's actually like
a little too overpowered,
but still really fun,
and can cause you
to put yourself
in a hole
where you can't escape
and you have to detonate on yourself,
so there is a balance
to it, but I think
like the fact that
like the bombs are on their own timer
that doesn't necessarily
like count down
on screen, there was something
more exciting about that
when you have more
of them because you kind of
have to think about your placement
rather than knowing
that you're safe with your controlled
detonations, that I wish
the controlled detonations
were actually
more puzzle-based
and just part
of the game
if they wanted to go that route.
I would have appreciated
if you had to
detonate things
in a certain order
to release a certain
enemy in a specific
direction, or the way that
enemies go, you need to trap
them in using your controlled
explosions, like it feels like
that was a missed element here,
and instead the controlled
explosions are just
a really powerful
different way to
play this game that could be fun
for any kind of
player, but kind of
brings down the
challenge of the
overall game. Yeah, I mean,
I'd actually say that I think
that applies to all the
power-ups. I feel like
the game design
could have
benefited from
being modeled
around the
power-ups. Once you get,
like you said, you get the detonation,
there should be a puzzle element
that requires you
to use that in some way
you couldn't before, or even
the blast radius
when you're making those crosses,
or how you can
put two bombs
that will detonate each other,
like there should be reasons to
use that stuff other than
feeling badass
and feeling cool.
There should be like, I don't know,
I wanted there to be
something a little more cognitive
that you have to think about your
placement as the
levels went on, but it never really
evolved in that direction.
Yeah, my earlier
levels sort of
ended up kind of being like that
because I didn't have the luxury
of having
more than one box
per explosion,
so it ended up
kind of being like, okay,
now I've got this power-up
that allows me to pull the
trigger myself,
so I see that
this enemy is
sort of trapped right now,
so I'm going to set two bombs,
one is going
to open up
the wall
that's keeping that enemy
boxed in, and then the
second one I will trigger
later so that
it gets blown
up by that as it starts
to come out, so I ended up
kind of using
that as a
puzzle-solving
thing, but it only
really mattered
because I didn't
have that other
power-up, so it's kind of
sandbox-y in that
way, you're not going
to get anything that's designed
to be this
puzzle-solving
tool, but you can
still get
creative with these things,
which I think is more important
than sort of
a hand-crafted
puzzle. What it came
down to for me too,
is this doesn't
have to be a
puzzle game in that respect
where you're
actually having to think about where
you place your bombs in order
to trap enemies,
it didn't have to be that kind of
level of game, like it is just
supposed to be a game where you
blow stuff up and have fun
doing that, so I respect that
they didn't go puzzle route,
but I think the
worst game design
decision they had
was that enemies
don't necessarily
have patterns,
and I understand
that certain enemies
are a little tougher
than others,
and certain enemies
behave differently
than others, but there needed to
be something where
like, for instance,
those balloon enemies, right,
I think they're the first ones you see
in the whole game, they needed to just
be an enemy that
goes side to side,
you know, left to right,
and you learn based
off of that, that like,
okay, I don't want to go in their hole
because then I'll
just get caught in their corner,
but I can bomb
them, and I can time
my bomb based
on like, them coming in
this particular direction,
instead, the game handles
everybody as a
free-thinking,
but without thought
really, roaming character
that doesn't,
like, sometimes it feels
like they know about your bombs,
sometimes it feels like they know
where you are, but as far as
I'm concerned, the whole thing
in terms of enemies is just completely
random, and more often
than not, they can just
run into your
explosions by
accident, they are actually
always walking
in the direction of your bombs
if you're placing them smart,
they don't know where these bombs
are in relation to you,
and I think
patterns would have helped something
like that if you had guys who
went in circles
and got, and like,
later on with the ghosts,
like, if they had like,
you know, because they can go through the
different blocks, if they had a
recognizable pattern
so that you
could think about where you're
going to place your bombs,
rather than just
being in this awkward situation
later on, when there's only
like a few enemies left,
where you're kind of like chasing
them around the screen,
and only ever
like, getting kind of
like, okay, well I'm going to
place one here,
and I have another one, so I'll place this
here, and then I trap them,
and that's great,
but there's also times where trapping
them isn't an option because you've
destroyed every
single block, and now they're
just roaming around
this stage randomly,
and you just kind of have to
hope that one
of your explosions is lucky enough
to hit them. They introduce
such a wide
variety of
enemies aesthetically,
but for the most part,
like most of them all do
the same thing, so it tricks you
into thinking like, oh, there's an
enemy variety, but they're
all kind of the same.
Well, I'd say that,
yeah, they definitely
don't have
patterns, but I think
that they do have tendencies.
Like, I remember the barrels,
they move a
little bit faster, but they stick
to a left-right
thing, or an up-down
thing, depending on
where,
like, whatever their
initial state was.
Like, they are much
less likely
to veer off
of a one-axis
path, but I think
that's okay. I mean,
I think that
if you just
have this grid,
and all the
enemies have
very predictable
behaviors, you're just
sort of optimizing,
like, your playthrough
will be, like,
how optimally
can I do this,
instead of, like, how can I,
like, sort of
crowd control this,
which is
also a
valid way to play the
game, or to design
the game. So I don't
think it needed to be this
cut-and-dry
pattern thing. Yeah,
I guess now that I'm looking at it,
I'm actually watching right now,
yeah, there are some that go
left and right,
yeah, that just wasn't as
noticeable to me. I still agree
with Mike, though. I feel like
having a lot
more specific patterns would
have helped
this game just help
the levels feel,
I don't know, like,
a little bit more, it would help
the levels. They would have
been tighter because you would
have had, you would have
had a path
in mind. Yeah,
that's it, you have a plan
of action. Right,
I'm not arguing that
they should all act
like Koopa Troopas,
right? That would
be a really boring Super
Mario Bros. game if you
ever only went up against
Koopa Troopas, but every
enemy in a
Mario Bros. game is
somewhat designed
to do a particular pattern.
I think the
Hammer Bros. are a good
example of something where
it feels really random
and you kind
of have to think about when are
they going to jump, when are
they going to throw hammers, when are
they going to do these things? I guess
I'm showing how bad
of a game designer I
would be if the only thing
I can think about is
movement patterns, but I'm sure
there's other things they could
have done, too, for these
enemies to
differentiate them on a
level that would make
them more interesting than
just these
guys float
around the screen and you
just have to make sure you
bomb them. Well,
so for example,
when I first saw the barrel
enemies, my first
thought was, oh, that must be
like a barrel of gunpowder
or something, and when I place a bomb,
they're going to blow up
my bomb immediately or
something. This is
something else I would have to think
about, like, okay, don't place
a bomb too close to the
barrel guy because he'll
blow up all my bombs or
something. I don't know, it doesn't
really make sense when I think about it,
but that kind of
thing that I would have to think
about would make the
game feel take longer
to get stale. Yeah,
I get
what you're saying, like, that is
another element
that, like,
if maybe
it just, like, actually just
made your explosion bigger and
then that way it could reach
you accidentally.
I get that.
Right. I sort of
had that intuition as
well. Yeah,
rather than, like, right now,
it's still just, granted,
there might be, like, little different
ways of figuring out
how to get people, like,
how to get each enemy
depending on which direction
they're moving, but it's
still always just bomb
all the enemies. Like,
I know that's the name of the game,
but, like, I feel like, I don't know,
there could be another level.
I've got one more,
one more example of
something I was thinking
of. It might kind of go back
to what we were talking about before
with the power-ups, but,
Sean, you mentioned
you were
doing something that was,
you were almost like creating
a little bit of a puzzle for yourself
that wasn't, like, in the game
design, and I was kind of doing
something similar where when I
had a very
large blast radius,
I would try and put
bombs at
the edge of another
bomb's blast radius in a
way where I could fill the
whole board as much as I
can, get as many enemies across
the whole board with one explosion
without having to detonate
more than once. It didn't
really make a difference,
because if I
didn't have them like that,
I could have just detonated them all one
after another and still gotten that
same range, but it was
just fun to me to do it that way,
and I kind of wished
that the game
would have rewarded me
for some way
in doing that. points stack
on each other, or just some
incentive to do something
different than just place
bombs and blow them
up until
you kill everything. I guess.
I mean, also,
if you frame it not so
much as solving a
puzzle or
solving something
that the game is laying out
in front of you, but a more
proactive way
of thinking of like, oh,
I'm laying a trap,
that's sort of how I
was looking at it,
and I
think that was sort
of my
reward was
knowing that I laid
this successful
trap. I know that
that's like
a very wishy-washy
way to argue your
point, but I
really don't know what
else could have been
more of an incentive.
Yeah, I mean,
look, I see what
you're saying too, and I think that
we're both, I mean, I agree with
both of us, if that makes
sense. I do think
there's definitely something to that
validation you have
just from the satisfaction of
figuring out a cool way of
doing it. I think one
way of incentivizing you,
which maybe wouldn't really
work for the people on this
podcast, I think we've all gone on
record saying we don't care
about points in games like
this, but if you
just made it so,
okay, this is worth
a thousand points, but if you
stack it with another one,
now it multiplies by
three or something. Every time
you kill
multiple enemies
at once, the points you
get increase exponentially are
just something to see a visual.
That would also help a bad cause.
I do think that
when Sean, when you said
crowd control,
that was like
an eye-opening thing for me
though, of like what
is actually the most fun part
of this game, which we were
kind of talking about earlier
and we lost track of when
we started getting pretty negative about
the game, but it is fun
when you have
like a lot
of power and a lot
of chaos on the screen
in terms of
like all
these different enemies, placing your
bombs, keeping track
of where they are.
You know, I think like
if the enemies were really
difficult, we might have
argued that this
game was like an NES hard
game where it's
like all these enemies are like
unfair now or
something like that. So I could see
that there's a
line. I do think at
the end of the day though, there is a point
in this game where you just
become like bomber god,
instead of
bomber man. And when you
have the flame
pass and the
bomb pass, which are two
not even late
game power ups,
they're just two power ups you can
stumble across that
allow you to walk
over your own bombs,
but then also
like dodge the
explosions of those
bombs regardless of
where you are. All of a sudden,
the whole game just
becomes like dodge
the enemies. And when you can
just lay out, you know,
I don't know what the limit is actually,
but let's say like you can lay out five
bombs and they can
have huge explosions
and you don't have to worry about
where they are. You just have to
make sure that they're hitting
enemies. It's very hard to
lose in that
particular scenario.
And that's where actually the game
becomes too
extreme in this,
you know, like it becomes,
it becomes a sense where it's like,
okay, I don't feel the
challenge anymore.
The challenge would
be me just like
taking off these
power-ups. One note that I
wanted to make, and it's sort of,
I guess it's a little offbeat,
the experience that
I likened this to
the most of like a
game I played recently would be
like Saints Row 4
where you're kind of,
you kind of exist in
this simulated version
of the previous
Saints Row games.
so you can like
hack, hack a simulation
like you're in the Matrix and you
basically become like a superhero playing
a GTA game and
it's so hard to
die and everything
dies so easily.
And you're just a
superhero. So,
but like that sort
of, that change from the
beginning of the game where you're just sort
of walking around
playing as like this
very pedestrian version
of a GTA clone to
the end of the game where you're
this invincible
god that just
flicks at enemies
and they explode.
That was sort of the experience I got,
but I had a lot of
fun when I was playing that game
in a very similar
way that I was
having a lot of fun
as I played through
Bomberman. So like,
yeah, you're overpowered,
but it's such a
goofy way to do it.
I just found it
entertaining. Yeah.
Your description
reminds me of
playing Crackdown
if you guys had played that.
Crackdown as well. It's very similar.
Where in the beginning you're just like a guy
and then by the end
of it you can jump
50 feet in the air
and survive huge
explosions. So Bomberman's like
that, but he can't jump. But he can roller
skate, which is pretty cool.
He can roller skate. Speaking of Bomberman's
movement for a quick
second, this was a weird
experience I had
playing the game and it's going to be
hard for me to explain this because
I've tried thinking
about it several times
now before we
recorded the episode.
Did you notice
something about the
size of Bomberman's
sprite on the maze
itself, right?
The maze itself
seems like it should
just be tile,
if you press the
down button, you'll move to the
next tile, and so on and so
forth, like a grid.
But it doesn't
really work like that
and there's actually
like some, some looseness
between the
hallways of
Bomberman where
like he can kind
of round the
corners of these
squares,
which is weird
because technically
they shouldn't have
circular edges on
these squares, but they do.
It was very
uncomfortable and
there was just something about
like, it caught me off
guard a lot when
I was placing bombs
because I think
that I'm placing
them on a particular tile,
but I'm not quite there.
I'm actually like a
little off and
maybe this carries
all the way back
from Legend of
Zelda where that is actually
a game where
you're very much on like a
particular grid
that you can move across.
This game has
like a looseness
to it that
felt very weird
the whole time I was playing.
I think it would
have felt more weird if you were
on a grid. Yeah, because there's
sort of like a timing effect
that comes with that and in a
timing based game
like this, I think that that
would have made the game feel a
lot more like
while you're
calling looseness
kind of weird, I think that if
you're stuck to
this grid, it would feel
even worse. Interesting,
because I guess I'm actually not
saying that it's
bad, you know,
I'm saying it actually made me
uneasy. Like there was a
weird, there was a mental break
for me while
playing this game
because of it
feeling like my
movement was like
slightly adrift
or something, you know,
like I wasn't exactly in
control of the
character, I was ever so
slightly off and
it's not true, you are in control
of the character at all times,
it just, you know,
it was like a visual psych out
for me. Maybe it's to
help round corners,
like if you put a bomb down
and then need to quickly escape so
you don't get stuck on a
corner, maybe that was
part of the intention. If I think about
like how I've
played, like how you play
Zelda or like a
classic RPG,
like you don't
really have much
of a, like you can,
can you kind of
imagine having that
control scheme and
playing a Bomberman
like game where it's
just like one block,
one block, like there really
isn't that much of
a, like you can't time
that, like it's just this
tempo.
Exactly, I hear you,
no, you're playing a math
game all of a sudden, you know,
you're trying to just
like calculate, calculate the,
it might as well have counted down
your spaces then,
like okay, you are five spaces
away from explosion,
four spaces away,
like I get that. It could be like a
Crypt of the Necromancer
kind of thing where it's a rhythm game.
Oh, that's cool. Necrodancer.
Necrodancer, yeah, right,
Necrodancer. Slightly different game.
I've only ever played
the Zelda one, so I just call it
Cadence of Hyrule,
mostly. Which is rad as well.
Yeah. So I probably should have done
the development section first
because this probably would have
set the stage better
for the kind of game
that, not only that we played,
but that others can expect
and maybe why it is
the way it is. This is a,
even though it's the first game
of 1989 on the NES,
this is a 1983
Japanese computer game
that was written in,
in basic for,
as like a tech demo
for Hudson Soft
back in like 1980
and then finally published
in 83. It never really like
went anywhere for a while
and then it all of a sudden
like exploded on personal
computers and then they were like,
oh, well the Famicom just came out,
so let's release it
there and it did come out there.
Eventually that Famicom port
gets to the NES here in 1989,
but the Famicom version
was developed
by the head of R&D,
Shinichi Nakamoto,
and he says,
he claims to at least,
have completed the task
of porting it to the Famicom
all by himself
in 72 hours.
I mean, I'm not a programmer
programmer, and I definitely wasn't
a programmer in the 80s,
but that still,
it still sounds kind of
outlandish to me.
It's either like,
Basic was very easy
to translate to Assembly
and this was a super simple game,
or, Nakamoto's just a liar.
I think he might be a liar.
I'm gonna go with the,
he was able to do it.
Nakamoto also added
in a 1995 interview
that he personally believes
that the Famicom version
of which he is solely
responsible for,
apparently, is the one and only
version of the game.
I would also find that
hard to believe, that this is the definitive
version of the original
Bomberman, considering that, like,
it ran on personal computers,
it ran on the MSX,
like, surely there's gotta be
a better version.
I did read that on the Wikipedia page,
that the NES version
was the version,
but I get,
I mean, maybe it's one of those
things where you don't realize
how good the arcade version
is until you finally see it,
but I can't really see
too many, like,
presentational improvements
that this game
can, could do.
I'm sorry, I feel like the only
improvements that this game
could have on other
systems is presentational,
because, like, the core gameplay,
like, it, it performs pretty well,
so, I don't know.
And that's ultimately
what I'm gonna get to
here for a second, a bigger picture thing,
if you will. This was a tech demo
for Hudson Saw.
Guy is named Bomberman,
he bombs,
uh, bricks,
and destroys funny enemies.
Why is this about
to explode
into, like,
like, a, you know,
gigantic franchise
with many,
many games, like,
would this first game,
would you really imagine
this, like, taking off
and being like,
well, we've gotta do more
of just this,
though. Like, we're not gonna add
too many more improvements.
It reminds me a lot
of, like, Lode Runner.
Remember when we covered the Lode Runner
episode and it was,
like, a bunch of sequels
came out, but they were just, like,
additional level packs
for Lode Runner.
And it's, like, was that really necessary?
Like, didn't you get enough
from, like, the 50 levels
that that game had? Now you needed,
like, another 99 level pack
where you don't add any new mechanics,
really, you're just making
more levels. That's ultimately
what the first couple
of Bomberman
spinoffs are gonna be,
sequels are gonna be.
So it's, like, it's really strange
that, I don't know,
this is, like, such a weird character
and game to get,
like, a huge franchise.
Imagine if, um,
you know, Mylon's Secret Castle
became, like, a big thing where,
like, oh, we gotta make another
Mylon's Secret Castle
game, like,
let's just make that a whole franchise
and Mylon will get
a puzzle game and he'll get
a platformer game
and he'll get a 3D game
and it's, like, my assumption
there, though, is, and I don't have
a precise idea
of, like, an answer to that,
but, but I will say
that I, I think maybe,
I mean, we've been,
I guess, moderately neutral
on this game, but I think we've
maybe leaned a little negative for what
I thought I was gonna talk about
on this episode. I did think this
was a pretty good
game for, for how simple
it is, um,
and it was satisfying and I
did have fun,
like, I did have fun
with it, and I think it's
at least enough
that I, that I can see
it warranting one sequel
and then if that
sequel suddenly
does some things
a lot better, like,
I feel like that there's room
for a, for a much
improved sequel
and I feel like
people would want that and then
it's not like
they were like, oh, Bomberman did great,
let's make a hundred other games,
they were probably like,
Bomberman did great, let's make one
other game and then that game does
really well and then the next game does
even better and
like, I assume that like
one of its sequels
is even better,
like, is even better in a
way that they were like, oh my god,
people are loving this now.
I guess in,
to respond to
what you said, Mike,
about like,
okay, Mylon Secret
Castle gets this
and whatever the
hell else, I don't remember,
those, I didn't really,
I don't think I enjoyed those games,
I barely remember what Mylon Secret
Castle even was
and the thing
about Bomberman is that it is
such a simple
concept, but it is a
systems-based game
and this is like
a term I throw
around whenever I
see one because it's such a,
like, that is the
philosophy of game
design that I think I subscribe
most to, that like,
it evolves over
time, like,
one experience is
going to be a little different than the next,
I think that's
what people liked,
I mean, and it's got just
like sort of that it,
like, that you can't
really describe
that Mylon Secret
Castle most definitely
does not have. I don't,
I guess I really don't know,
how else to,
I guess, defend this,
defend this game,
I don't know. I guess I'm not
asking for defense,
I'm just asking if
anybody else is as surprised as I am
that a character
that just plants
bombs and they,
again, a top-down game
and they just explode in directions
and any Bomberman
in the mainline games,
which is a lot of them,
any game that you play
is going to start off
with the same
limitations of,
like, your bomb can only
be destroyed
in a one-by-one
cross-tile fashion
and you can only
drop one at a time,
like, the fact that every single game
starts like that,
maybe I have a little
bit of a bias here
because, and I am not saying
this as a joke, I've been playing
Bomberman games
all day in preparation
for this episode.
I decided,
it's 1989, we got sequels
and spinoffs, let me try and
actually tackle
some of these other games so that I'm
not just talking about them based
on what I read, let me play
some of these games.
And there came a
point where I realized that this would be
a six-to-eight-hour
podcast if I talked
about every Bomberman
game. Yeah, don't do that, Mike.
I had no idea.
I had no idea
that there was over
20 main Bomberman
games, that there are over
10 portable Bomberman
games, that there is a
Bomberman arcade
world also that,
like, is sometimes known
as Atomic Punk
in the West
and not Bomberman.
That sounds pretty It is pretty cool.
I had no idea
that there were a whole line of
Bomberman mobile
games, like Bomberman
Play IQ,
which I can only
imagine is like an IQ test with
Bomberman, like that's how
we probably have a Bomberman love
tester game in here
somewhere. One of those things
where you, it's like an arm
wrestling machine.
Yes, and it tells you
if you're in love or not.
Yeah, I see. There's Bomberman
Wars, which was a
Japanese-only
tactical role-playing
game featuring
the Bomberman cast.
There's, don't forget
Robo Warrior,
that game we played just a while ago,
like that's a Bomberman game.
Bomberman Panic
Bomber, which is like
Puyo Puyo meets
Tetris. Then there's the
Bomberman LAN games,
which are like this kind of like
regular Bomberman games,
so I don't know why they get their own section
on the wiki.
And then there's
also like Bomberman Act
Zero, which was like a
reboot, a gritty reboot
of Bomberman
in like 2012.
2012. Yeah.
It's crazy,
it's crazy. And then there's
a whole clone section too,
of just cloned
Bomberman games
that were made by other companies,
mostly Chinese,
but like that
are just taking
the same Bomberman
thing and just removing him,
but the idea of
explosions and grids
still being like
the main thing you play as.
I can't believe
so many people
find this kind
of game so satisfying that
they would go on to make 200
versions of it.
Yeah, when you put it that way,
I mean, it is, yeah,
like I would
not have expected that level
of a future
for Bomberman
from this game,
but I don't know.
I mean, I guess it was just,
it just was
like the perfect job interview
where it was like, okay,
you've shown us
that you're okay,
you're good, you know,
you're kind of fun. And then it's like,
all right, let's see what you can do now,
really. Because what was
the game, I'm already forgetting,
what was the game we just played
a few weeks ago that was the same
Robo Warrior. That wasn't fun.
No, was it Robo Warrior?
Is that what I'm thinking of?
Oh, I thought you were
talking about with Bomberman
in the...
No, no, there's another
warrior placing bombs through
a bunch of
solid objects. Yeah,
Robo Warrior. Wow,
I, okay, I didn't even think
I was on the Robo Warrior episode.
You probably weren't. Yeah,
you probably weren't. I wasn't.
There was another game that we played
that I was on. It wasn't fun.
Okay, well, either way, there's another game
that we played recently that I was on.
I'll look it up in a minute when I'm done talking
and I'll chime back in.
But, that was not fun.
And, it was doing like
the same things. It just, I don't know,
it just didn't,
it just didn't hit the elements right.
And, and it, I didn't enjoy it at all.
And this game I did enjoy.
So, maybe, like I said,
they just were able to keep building on that.
It's not really an answer
to your question. I just don't know,
but, it's Pac-Man.
Pac-Man does the same
goddamn thing every time.
But, Pac-Man is an icon.
Everyone doesn't get sick
of Pac-Man.
They, they will go and play Pac-Man.
Uh, it's,
it's a, I think that's sort of a,
a good analogy for that.
I think that, going along with Pac-Man,
this game is very approachable.
It's really easy to,
not have any idea what you're doing
and then start playing it
and then understand what the point is.
And I think that maybe
that's where it gets so much,
like, that's why it gets
so many spin-offs
because so many people
can immediately
understand how to play.
There's not, like,
a whole lot of skill
in the very beginning
that you need. That's fair.
That's definitely true.
And, to be honest,
I think, you know,
anybody in today's gaming sphere
that knows Bomberman
knows that what actually
made these games really successful
is the multiplayer component,
which is not present
in this game,
but became a huge thing
of, like,
four-player, five-player,
seven-player, eight-player,
ten-player Bomberman.
Like, there is on the Sega Saturn,
Saturn Bomberman,
which is a ten-player
Bomberman game.
And another game
that's just crazy, Bomberman,
uh, had the first-ever
HD video game
in 1993.
Uh, it came out
only in, like, on a special computer
in Japan that they brought
to, like, special events,
but it was played
on, um,
on a 16x9,
uh, TV and had,
like, a huge,
um, like,
a huge scope to it.
Everything was very tiny
on screen, and you were just
only Bomberman
versus other Bomberman.
Like, there were no enemies on the screen,
and you were just,
like, kind of,
like, it looked like Minesweeper.
You're just blowing away blocks,
trying to ultimately, like,
create holes
for other players,
uh, to be,
like, trapped into your,
uh, your plots or whatever.
So it's, like, really funny
that the game
would start off
as a single-player game,
but then explode into this multiplayer
madness that I think
most people are familiar
with Bomberman for now.
I think you play
any of the
Bomberman games after the first
maybe two or three,
and they all have
this multiplayer component,
which it's become famous for.
I could see how that
would be really fun, too,
because you're actually going up against
somebody who has,
you know, like,
a brain, but also,
yeah, brain is actually
what I wanted to say,
so thanks for saying that.
You're welcome. But, like, you know,
just, like, even some kind of
attack against you,
you know? A lot of the enemies
in the screen, it's like, just don't walk into them.
Just walk away
when you see them and you'll be fine.
It's really strange.
Bomberman's a huge franchise,
so we're not going to cover
all these games and sequels
and spinoffs, but we will try to cover
a lot of it in
Bomberman 2
on the NES
in 1993.
Who was excited
for Bomberman 2?
Probably. I am now.
35? Your enthusiasm
has convinced me.
Might be 40.
Yeah, it'll be a long time.
Yeah. I did want to talk about
three Bomberman games
that I played, and that is
Bomberman 93
for the TurboGrafx-16.
It was,
that was the first one
in the line
that I was playing where it actually
started to feel more fun.
There was a lot of, it was a lot of colors to it.
Uh, the game moved a lot faster.
Uh, the actual,
like, layouts of the levels
changed, which was nice.
And, that's how I expected
my Bomberman to be,
so this is, Bomberman 93 is where
I would suggest
is, like, the entry point.
But then I played
Bomberman 94,
and Bomberman 94
is just as good,
actually, better,
than Bomberman 93.
And now, you can ride around
on animals,
like kangaroos and stuff like that,
while you're Bomberman,
and destroy more
than just, like, blocks.
You destroy, um,
flowers are the,
are the blocks in certain levels.
Um, fire,
like, cans on fire
are another one.
Like, it's just interesting
that they finally, like,
said, well, what if he did
other things other than bricks? And when did this come out?
Yeah, it's funny that,
that, Bomberman 94,
so 1984. That sounds like the 90s.
It's funny it took him that long to get to,
to get the idea that,
like, there are other things
other than bricks that can be blown up.
What about the roller skates?
So was it? You're hopping in a kangaroo pouch,
I assume, that's how you travel.
Well, you just go faster,
that's all. But, do you,
like, if I'm in a kangaroo pouch
and it's hopping me along
while I'm tossing bombs out of it,
like, do I keep my roller skates on?
That seems like it'd be painful.
I don't think you're ever actually
wearing roller skates. Are you riding the kangaroo pouch
or are you riding the kangaroo?
You're riding the kangaroo,
you're not in the pouch. So,
I guess one question I'd mention,
is this like a, is this like a Madden thing?
Like, you got Bomberman 94,
is there always,
like, a Bomberman date?
No. Bomberman 2K11?
Yeah. That's just for those two
Bomberman games,
actually, believe it or not.
And then it gets into
the Super Bomberman series,
which was, uh,
all on the Super Nintendo
or the Super Famicom.
Uh, some of them didn't come
to the Super Nintendo, but Super Bomberman 1,
uh, has four-player multi-tap support
and, um,
not really an improvement
over Bomberman 94,
so I didn't feel like mentioning it,
but Super Bomberman 2,
now that is my jam,
okay? This is the one I played
the most of by far.
Um, 2 is the one that's really
worth talking about because it's like,
there's tons of power-ups now.
It's, it is just pure chaos.
There are boss fights
and interesting boss fights
at that too, not just like,
bomb the other enemy,
uh, in a grid-like fashion.
Like, they get into mechs
and then you have to,
like, dodge their patterns
and lay out bombs,
but then, like, watch out because
they have bombs too.
Very, very cool.
Uh, and there's also,
like, uh,
steps and stairs
and different, like,
layers to the,
uh, to the levels,
so you actually have to think about,
like, where you are.
There's TNT that,
like, blows up different puzzle
aspects of it,
so you have to, like, think about,
like, all right, if I blow up the TNT here,
I'm gonna destroy a bunch of,
um, a bunch of land
or a bunch of, um,
my power-ups
and stuff like that, so it's a lot more thoughtful.
I thought that was really cool.
So I had to play Super Bomberman 2,
I was like, all right,
I'll try 3, 4, and 5,
and it was just shocking
how bad 5 was.
5 was actually,
like, Super Bomberman 1,
again. I was like,
why? Why did they go back like that?
But I guess they ran out of time
to develop those games
and just said, eh,
whatever. We could release this.
That's more than likely
how it went down.
So that's my experience
playing Bomberman all day.
Uh, I highly recommend
everybody at least check out
a few Bomberman games
because there's a lot of them.
You can't go wrong, right?
Don't play Bomberman Act Zero,
though, because there was no reason
for a gritty reboot
of Bomberman.
And I mean gritty,
like the edge is unreal.
Yeah, it's pretty bad. Anyway,
we've talked a lot about Bomberman.
Now we have to decide
if it will be our very first game
of 1989 on the Essential Games list.
I want to tell you
that I looked up that game I was talking about.
And it was? It was, uh,
it was Robo Warrior.
Yeah, we thought so.
Uh-oh. I don't know why I thought
I wasn't on that episode.
I looked back, though,
the one before that was Rampage,
which I wasn't on. But,
so that was what I was thinking of.
But Robo Warrior was so unmemorable
that I didn't even remember
the name of it.
Yeah, so let's roll that music again.
New year,
same list,
but not really
because we did remove
some last episode.
So if you want to know
what the latest
Essential Games list is,
it'd be great if we had a website,
but we don't. So instead,
listen to every single episode
and make like a,
I don't know, have a notebook
where you write down
the games that become Essential,
and that's the best way to keep track.
It's almost as if, like,
all these social media outlets
that we have, we should probably,
like, write it down somewhere.
That's a great idea,
Sean. So just for this week only,
I will post an image
of every Essential game.
Nice. Anyway,
it's time to talk about if Bomberman's gonna be
on that image. So,
Sam, give me your thoughts.
I think this is a fun game.
It's certainly a classic game.
We've heard a lot about it.
It's, you know,
we've talked about it.
It's a good time,
but it's fairly simple also.
And I think that this is
a definite play it,
but for me, it's just not quite essential.
Fair enough. Joe,
your thoughts? Yeah,
I'm kind of in, like,
the exact same place.
I did think it was fun.
I did have a good time,
but it's really not something
that I think,
if I'm being honest with myself,
I don't think I would seek it out
ever to play.
So I feel like it's like a play it.
If you have access to it,
yes, play it. It's great.
But, like, I'm not even sure I'd say
go out of your way to play it.
I think it was,
you won't regret it,
but definitely not essential.
Sean? That's really disappointing
because I was going all out.
I was gonna, I was gonna hit the ground running
and vote this game essential.
I'm still gonna do that,
at least, you know, for posterity's sake
because I,
I really, even,
because since I haven't been exposed
to any future Bombermans,
I can't use the excuse of,
like, play this one instead
and, like, it's already been done
and, you know, there are better versions.
Like, I don't really have that
in my back pocket.
So, I just had a,
it was a joy to play this game.
I really appreciated
the very quickly escalating
intensity of the game
and that,
like, you know, that ever
elusive feeling
of power
that you, you get over the course
of the game sort of in a,
like, gradious on,
on speed.
Um, so,
yeah, I mean, I,
my vote would have,
it is essential.
It just won't,
it just won't matter.
Because you've been, yes,
you've already been outvoted.
And I will say,
in, in defense of Bomberman,
in defense of Joe and Sam,
and in defense of Sean,
that, this is a,
this is a game that I think made sense
as the very first Bomberman entry.
So, maybe it made even more sense
when it first came out in 83
or whatever. I was hard on this game
for, like, launching a franchise.
But I was only saying that
because of, like, the ridiculous nature
of the game.
Like, just the design ideas
of, like, this guy plants bombs
and destroys things.
Like, I just think that's crazy.
But video games often are,
are crazy.
Uh, maybe they're a little less,
uh, maybe they're more grounded now.
But, I think Bomberman has all the makings
of a good video game.
I just can't,
like, I can't put this on
the essential games list
because now I have gone
and explored.
And I will say that multiplayer Bomberman
is the future of Bomberman.
And that I think this is a nice start.
But this is,
uh, this is,
this is almost like,
you know, we get into this a lot
with franchises where it's like,
yeah, this is Bomberman. Like,
ultimately, every game just iterates
on the ideas that were laid out here.
And that's true. Like,
even the Super Bomberman 2
that I was talking about that I fell in love with today,
like, that is really just
Bomberman again.
But they thought of, like,
some new power-ups and they had better graphics.
Like, you know,
so they were able to make a more fun game.
However, every Super Mario Bros.
game after Super Mario Bros.
1 is still just kind of
basing itself around
the design philosophies
of Super Mario Bros. 1.
but that first game
feels really good.
I can't say
that Bomberman
feels really good
after going
to these future games.
And for that reason,
I can't put it
on the Essential Games list
because for me,
the thing that represents
more than just NES games.
But there's only NES games
on it. Correct.
Because when we get to
all the other consoles,
we'll start adding
those consoles games
as well. We'll start doing,
like, 10 games a week
okay? We'll post Monday,
8 a.m., Tuesday,
6 p.m.,
Wednesday. Yeah,
we'll do it because you know why?
Because we have a great set of listeners
who have listened
to 150-something episodes now.
Maybe almost 160.
We're not going to do anything special for that
but maybe, maybe we will.
I just got the official tally.
It's 155 episodes
plus four specials
and a bunch of unreleased
Gaten episodes
for Japanese games
that we once recorded
and haven't released.
So if you want to hear
some of that stuff,
let us know on Twitter.
Be like, hey, I want unreleased
Japanese episodes
on my podcast feed.
I'm going to leak them. Yeah,
well, you could try to leak them
but ultimately they're going to come out.
It's kind of like, think about it
like Pokemon cards,
right? Everybody had at least
one Japanese Pokemon card
but you don't remember how you got it.
Like, how did you get that
Japanese Pokemon card?
You didn't import it.
You didn't order it online.
Like, it just kind of, all of a sudden
you checked your binder one day and you're like,
oh, this back looks different.
And that's what, you're actually freaking me out
right now. That's, that's actually very accurate.
It happens all the time
and that's ultimately
what's going to happen with these episodes.
One day you're going to check your feed
and be like, wait a minute,
I didn't change my region
to Japan
and they're just going
to be there. So,
we're all going to be speaking Japanese
inexplicably. Yeah.
Please let us know
on Twitter at NostalgiaCast
if you want to hear those episodes
or if you listen
to this episode and have thoughts
about Bomberman because often enough
people have thoughts
about these games and they usually
tell us we're wrong.
So, we want to hear
how wrong we were.
But not Sean.
Don't tell him how wrong he was
because he thinks
he's right. I'm always right.
Anyway, next week we got
a special Sesame Street
123 episode
for you. If there's not
enough proof that we are going
to play every single NES game
look no further
than Sesame Street
123 developed by
Rare. So,
I'm expecting
Big Bird
meets Donkey Kong
Country style game.
I don't know about the rest of you guys.
I can't wait. These are the games
I live for. I'm Michael Esposito.
You can find me at Esposito Film
on Twitter and I'll talk to you soon. I'll talk to you soon.